Okay Mike, are you ready for a quiz?
>> Uh-huh. Okay, so, here, let me, let me set up the, the situation for
you. So a man goes to see his doctor, okay, because his back hurts or something.
>> Aww.
>> And she gives him a, I know, it's really sad. It's his, the left side
of his lower back, he's been playing too
much racquetball. Anyway, so a man goes to
see a doctor, and she gives him a lab test. Now this test is pretty good,
okay? It returns a correct positive. That is,
if you have the thing that this lab test
is testing for, it will say you have it 98 percent of the time, okay? So it only
gives you a false positive two percent of the
time. And at the same time, it will return
a correct negative, that is if you don't have
what the lab test is testing for, it will
say you don't have it. 97% of the time,
so it has a false negative rate of only 3%.
>> Wait, hang on. So, just, what's his problem?
>> Oh, that's the question. So, the test
looks for a disease. So, give me a disease.
>> Spleen?
>> Okay, I like that. So the test looks for
spleentitis. Now spleentitis is such a rare disease that nobody's ever
heard of it, And it turns out that it's so rare that
only about this fraction of the population has it. Okay?
>> Mm-hm.
>> That make sense? So we're looking for spleentitis. It's a
very rare disease, but this test is really good at determining
whether you have it or determining whether you don't have it
>> Can I tell you that, its,
spleentitis appeared zero times in google. [LAUGH] So
it really is quite rare.
>> It really is quite rare. But what does
google know? OK, so you got it all Michael?
>> Yeah. So its a really rare disease
and we have a very accurate test for it.
>> Good. Man goes to see the doctor. She gives him a lab test. Its a
pretty good lab test. Its checking for spleentitis,
relatively rare disease and the test comes back positive.
>> Oh.
>> Yes. So, test is positive. So, here is the quiz question.
>> Should we be
net, notifying his next of kin?
>> Yes. Does he have spleentitis?
>> You said, just said he had spleentitis.
>> No, I said the test says he had spleentitis. Or the
test looks for spleentitis, and the test came back positive. So, does
he have spleentitis? Yes or no? Alright, before I try to answer
that can I just, ask for clarification, can I get a clarification?
>> Please.
>> So the 98 is a percentage and the
97 is a percentage, is .008 also a percentage?
>> No it's not.
So if I wanted to convert it to a percentage it would be .8%.
>> Got it. Alright, now I think I have, what I need.
>> Okay, alright, so, you think about it. Go.